hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2018 world blitz
championship Carson is the sole leader
going into round 15 sorry inter around
22 but he knocking is certain he needs a
victory in this round to ensure that he
remains first as a Polish Grandmaster
Ian gist of Duda has been following his
excellent performance every round of the
way so if he draws and Duda wins his
game then they could tie and they could
go into tiebreaks so really cousin needs
a win here and I don't know if you
remember a few days ago before the rapid
and place world championship started I
said how Anton horrible is such an
excellent player and that he always has
great results and here he faces cross
and in the final round
he can't be first but if he wins this
and if some other pairings go his way he
could definitely go from from first to
third not first but maybe second and
third and of course you're playing
against Carson in the final round you do
want to make the best of it
and this game really illustrates how how
cruel chairs can be especially blitz
chess when you've played a spectacular
tournament and then you you just need to
play one more game
but then anything can happen so without
further ado let's just check out what
happens here
d4 by carlson and nice to f6 Knight to
f3 d6 Bishop to g5 so the Toure attack
is on the board we have h6 the classical
defense against the tour a push up to h4
and now d6
we have a c3 strengthening in the center
and g5 now going after the bishop bishop
to g3 and the night to h5 now pressuring
the bishop and g3 also preparing f5 in
some in some lines crossing goes efore
Bishop to g7 and Bishop to d3 by Carson
and here nice to d7 and as of this
moment on we have a new game that has
never been played before night BT to buy
Carlsen and now b6 score both prepares
to develop his LightSquared Bishop Queen
t2 grabbing the hold of the C 4 square
also deciding maybe to go Queens and
maybe to go King side most
likely will go queenside as if this
capture ever happens the caution wants
to open up the H file by capturing H
captures on g3 we have Bishop to b7
coral Buffy and Carols the bishop and
now comes nice to see for this night can
now come to III and from III all sorts
of ideas are possible but you will
definitely be controlling d5 and f5 and
also g4 perhaps in some lines Queen to
e7 core above also prepares a castle in
maybe king a queen side maybe king side
and now comes the night f2 d2 across and
wants to push f4 Knight captures and g3
we have H captures and g3 and now comes
a six
we have f4 by Carlsen and now comes D
five with ecad force on d5 and here core
above could capture with ecad force on
d5 and offer a trade of Queensland but
he goes at Bishop captures on d5 he
wants to keep the Queen's on the board
as well he also really wants to beat
Carson in the final round
Knight e3 by Carson the knight now
finally gets to this very nice square
Bishop back to b7 and now comes the
Bishop to b4 Carson wants to exchange
this light square Bishop Bishop captures
Knight captures and now comes f5
horrible pushes the knight back but it's
not the greatest of moves Carlsen goes
nice to d2 but there is a better move it
simply the game you know a very a lot of
time on the clock for both of them but
feel free to quickly pause the video and
try to find the move course and missed
here all right so it's a very nice
tactic for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations it's a very nice
boots tactic and for the zoo who just
won't enjoy the show Knight captures and
g5 is the idea and now after pawn
captures now you get looked after son h8
Bishop captures and Queen to h5 with
check connecting with the bishop here
Queen to f7 blocking Queen captures on
h8 Knight will block and now comes F
captors and g5 why these up two points
in a better position most likely it
would be winning for my for white but
it's it's blitz you know it's hard to
connect everything with with the Queen
h5 check so Knight back to d2 and now
comes Knight to f6
we have castles by Carson Carson goes
for the
inside castle and here coral Bob also
has to decide what to do with his king
is still in the center of the board but
should not really doing all that much in
g7 as this D for ponies is very strong
horrible would like the Castle kingside
and push c5 you're not really castling
queenside anytime soon as Queen captures
on a sex will be a problem but this is
why I said that chest is very cruel and
that especially blitz chest where you
play an entire tournament beautifully
and then you mess up like this in the
final round here core both played King
side castle a bit too soon and again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the move cousin played that one him
first place in this world 2018 world
with championship for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are now a world blitz champion and for
those who who just wanna enjoy the show
the Queen on a seven is undefended soul
Knight captures on a 5-1 core above
Saudis he was very unsatisfied one can
even say disgusted with himself and it
was in this position I moved 21 that
Anton horrible resigned the game there's
nothing really to do here you could you
can't capture of course you lose the
Queen and if you don't capture then you
have to move the Queen to protect this
exponent but then comes Knight captures
on h6 with check captures rook captures
and then you're you're down two points
and there's really no point in
continuing this game this rope is coming
to h1 the night is coming to f3 the g5
the Queen can easily come into the game
it's a completely lost position for
black so quarter ball doesn't even
consider playing this even though yeah
yeah there's no point there there's not
even a remote possibility that you would
trick Magnus in in a situation like this
quite quite an eventful round
indefinitely and it's really a shame for
the young polaron mastery on she strove
Duda as he won his final round and he
got second place we have the pair we
have the rank ranking here these are
this these are the final rankings after
21 rounds so as you can see Carlsen in
first place with 17 points and Duda in
second place alone with 16 and a half
point
so you can see how the two of them are
so far away in front of everyone then
you have with 14 and a half points
Nakamura alone in third place with 14
and a half points and then we have with
14 points 11 our neon Peter Svidler
Napoleon a segue Carrick and Dimitri and
rakin not Dimitri under 18 already on 13
and a half then what is La Barthe Mia
vanish Giri with 13 and half an eagle
serene Maxime at lack of shahe dear mama
dr of nikita feet above daniel dubov the
winner of the rapid section got 15 place
in the boot section vladimir fellow
sieve also 13 and half anton horrible
now with 13 after losing this final game
to Magnus Croson so yeah there as
Nakamura won his game then that means
core above could not advance to third
place but if if Nakamura didn't then who
knows what might happen
Boris Gelfand with 13 then drive Alexey
alpha Dudley admit react Evancho
gristick alexander alexander Zubov and
sergei jigoku the highest-rated blitz
player on leeches in 24th place sir
those were the standings after the final
round and we also have the all of the
players cross and faced during this
blitz event so here you can see in first
round against the even pop of a victory
then a draw against Sergei Grigoryants
then a victory against Vitali tariff
then again a victory against Martin boss
whichever next victory with the black
piece where he trapped my dance queen
alexei sheer of drawers with officer
gate draw yeah young fish to do a
victory and also a victory against the
stronger iranian grand master ali reza
furiosa a draw against Dmitry Andre Kim
then a victory against Peter Svidler
worse will or missed that rook to g3
rook captures g3 move a win against
Levin orange and then a draw against
Ladislav artemiev then starting today's
around with a win against onigiri a win
against one cow then i win against
samsara nazi deep of a win against
Sevilla volleyball then a draw against
Nakamura Dragons Gelfand victory against
Medea of draw against Napoleon and a
victory in the final
against and horrible and also one very
interesting moment that in in the
penultimate round he faced Napoleon and
yang was late for two minutes I think
one minute forty eight seconds and he
has three minutes on the clock so he or
she only had one minute on the clock
when he sat down he had the white piece
he played a few moves and then crossing
over the draw but how are you late for
two minutes in a three minute game I
thought it was again the problem with
the toilets because everyone said that
there's a problem with the toilets
Alexander Grisha wall also mentioned it
in his interview I remember once I
played in the Croatian League and there
was this huge huge problem with the
toilets there was only one toilet and
they put a like a hundred players in one
playing hall and a it was a classical
event but if we went to the toilet you
you lost like 15 minutes on the clock it
was it was impossible to play but yeah
really really interesting stuff and the
once again
too bad for young cheese to do the who
played like afghan-american Shengo said
young Christophe Duda is the winner is
the human winner of the tournament as
Carlson's performance here is simply
godlike so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it hopefully I will be
able to cover some more games I don't
know if I will be doing any games
tomorrow but after that we're entering
the 2019 I will slowly be collecting
your materials to start to the
subscribers video and we will slowly be
starting the Capablanca saga
yeah I think that's pretty much it we
have a couple we have a lot of uploads
in this past few days as these are the
rapid and the Blitz but I do hope you
enjoyed that as well so thank you should
think all and I will see you soon